Possible.
And spas is a desperate desire to
understand the world better so that we
don't blow it up.
I mean,
that sounds rather simplistic,
but I start from the insight that most
versions of the way the world works,
that a highly [inaudible] of the sort
that one encounters in the social and
political sciences are wrong.
They don't capture anything like the
complexity of the historical process.
They're often actually deeply
misleading.
Like the democratic peace theory,
the theory that if all Paris were
democratic,
that would be no war because democracies
don't make war.
That there's an enormous literature on
this and most of it is rubbish.
It comes.
No in no way close to describing the
world.
A great deal of Ford has written about
the economic process is very good
applied mathematics that simply doesn't
describe this world.
It described another imaginary world of
perfect information,
the quiddity and a whole range of other
assumptions that don't pertain.
So my initial insight is this world is
highly complicated.
It works in very strange ways.
There are all kinds of,
uh,
nonlinearities which aren't captured by,
the simplifying models that social
scientists posit.
If we can understand the world better
and get a little closer to seeing,
uh,
how uncertain and complex it's workings
are,
then we may stand a chance of avoiding
the kinds of disaster that characterized
the 20th century.
I have studied 20th century disasters.
It's been one of my major interests.
I wrote about the German hyperinflation.
I wrote a book about the first World
War.
Then I wrote a book about the Second
World War.
I'm engaged in writing through my
biography of Kissinger,
a book about the Cold War.
Uh,
and that's a lot of death,
manmade death due to organize lethal
violence.
Uh,
and if you can work out why,
say between 118,
200 million people died,
violent desks and the 20th century.
And that shouldn't have happened,
right?
Because the 20th century,
it was supposed to be a century of
unparalleled economic and scientific
progress.
And it was,
and yet it was also a century in which
to horrendous violence occurred.
And that violence that emanated from
some of the most sophisticated
societies.
Figuring out why that happened seems
like a pretty important undertaking
though.
I certainly wouldn't put it up there
with finding a cure for cancer,
but it's what I do.
Uh,
and my hope is that each time I write a
book,
I've,
I've had at least added some small
amount to or understanding of,
of what went wrong.
The other thing that motivates me is,
uh,
is an interesting,
the things that work because I'm a,
an economic historian first and
foremost,
and particularly a financial historian.
I'm fascinated by the extraordinary
success capitalism as a way of
organizing economic activity.
I'm especially fascinated in the way
that financial systems have arisen in
certain places at certain times.
Uh,
and the benefits that they have
conferred in the sense that through a
good financial system,
you get resources better allocated than
in the absence of one.
Uh,
so another part of what I do is to try
and understand that better because when
we're not fighting wars where usually
caught up in the,
uh,
extraordinary ups and downs,
of financial markets and processes like
globalization but are not new,
we talk about them as if they're new,
but actually quite old,
go back to at least 1700.
Uh,
so these are the things that get me out
of bed in the morning.
I just want to understand that stuff
better.
Why the wars?
Why the stock market bubbles and busts,
uh,
in the hope that a historical approach
to these problems will actually yield
better insights than some of the other
approaches that people take.
[inaudible].